at one point in my life
is when I had arrived at 20 hours of
solo flying I had gotten in and and
learned to fly ahead and was doing okay
I thought it was but I ground looped
that's what they call
and I played it goes off to one side 106
year old World War II pow veteran
Vincent shank sitting down with eight
news now about what he remembers from
his past a funny story he recalls shank
a first lieutenant in the U.S Army Air
corps was a plane Navigator during World
War II captured by Nazis he spent years
in prison camps across Europe but was
eventually freed and while shank
couldn't verbalize a lot from his past
he did have a lot to say about his
present particularly from this morning's
Veterans Day Parade held downtown it
turned out was fantastic
millions of billion people they were
grateful they all wanted to shake my
hand
and see how great it was that
see us and talk to us in person his
daughter Nancy shank sharing how lucky
she feels to still have her father by
her side and on a day like today where
his legacy is remembered yeah I'm so
proud of him because really the World
War II veterans there's hardly many left
and I think truly that was the greatest
generation